a very distinguished panel uh today um
i'll just do a very brief introduction
uh
to everyone uh just in the context of
this panel so
so the panel consists of scott aronson
who we don't need to introduce here but
i'll just say that um
you know his um his article on reading
the fine print
is uh is sort of what we want from him
in the panel uh
to keep keep everything everybody honest
in terms of
machine learning uh andres gillian you
already heard is
is uh one of the principal authors of
the of this
quantum singular value transform that
that
erin talked about today um uh
ravi khannan is is our representative
of um you know he's one of the uh one of
the great
algorithms in classical uh linear
algebra
so he represents that side of the
of uh of the equation
uh you're done yes uh only this is um
uh you know he he was um he was
uh he's been working very intensely in
quantum machine learning in particular
he's the head of quantum algorithms at
qc there he was
part of this um terenidious uh prakash
um recommendation algorithms uh
um algorithms um um you know the quantum
algorithm
recommendation systems and
patrick uh revit trust from
from cqt uh you know has worked
extensively on quantum machine learning
and actually including quantum finance
he was he was on the
very influential 2017 nature paper on
quantum machine learning
so um without further ado i'll just
open open up the floor to the to the
panelists to
um you know to give a two to three
minute
uh uh commentary on
on you know their reaction to you in
stock or to quantum machine learning in
general and
um and we'll proceed from there
so scott maybe um well all right
i i appreciated the talk uh
it's always good to uh to hear from from
ewin i mean even though
my my role in this uh uh in in ewing's
story was mostly just giving you in this
problem
uh to work on but i'm you know i'm i'm
proud of that role
uh and um uh
you know i i kept thinking you know
since
since since she she mentioned this uh
uh 2014 survey article i wrote called
you know a read the fine print
uh i kept thinking about like if if i
were to write it again today
or or update it like would anything be
different right like what
has uh changed in the outlook for
quantum machine learning over the last
seven years or so
and uh you know and and it looked like
you know there were there would really
be
two main things right one is just you
know
uh uh this sequence of the quantizations
that you know that's uh started with
with ewen's work
uh that you know i like like what i i
sort of
warned abstractly in that 2014 article
that such a thing could happen
but you know i think people didn't take
it uh seriously until it actually did
happen
uh so you know it's it's uh it's funny
that way right uh uh
and and i i i think you know yeah uh uh
um ewing had
this this nice uh graphic of i guess the
the
growing purple was it or the growing you
know like a a
almost like like like uh um a mordor or
something or like that you know the uh
some dark wizard you know taking over
the uh uh
the quantum machine learning algorithms
the you know dequantizing one after the
next
and uh so so i i think
um you know just just like you know in
in 2014 i would say i mean
uh like when i when i uh talk
to business people or jew journalists or
i give colloquia and people ask me
about how is quantum computing going to
revolutionize machine learning you know
the answer i give them is
well you know eventually there should be
grover type speed ups
and as for whether there are exponential
speed ups
for any machine learning problem that
people care about in practice
and that would survive uh you know
dequantization you know evanization
whatever you call it
uh um i don't know right i think the
jury is still
out on that i think we we lack any
example that is you know nearly as
compelling as
let's say factoring or quantum
simulation
for quantum algorithms more broadly and
i think you know that's
the answer i would have given in 2014
and that's still the answer that i would
give today
you know despite uh um all that's
happened
now the other thing that that i would
change is that so
so much of this uh has been re um
you know can now be sort of rephrased in
this much more
general language of blocking codex right
so it might be that the upshot is
is the same but we now have this this
sort of more more powerful language for
talking about everything both the
quantum upper bounds and the uh
uh and the and the d and and and and the
uh dequantizations of them and i think
that's something that came through
clearly in anyone's talk so anyway i'm
happy to hear
you know this is this is not i would say
the area that i'm expert in and
i'm happy to hear other people's
thoughts
great um uh
i had a question for you but i'll wait
for for the rest of the panel uh
andres
yeah i i think that yeah indeed even
stock was
uh really really nice in in like putting
together
like summarizing this this language the
block encodings and and then how
you can you can actually quantize it and
and and draw a direct parallel i think
it's
it's very nice that that that like these
techniques developed by
and and all these improvements in
quantum machine learning came from
quantum physics like this linear
combination of militaries
first appeared in a paper in andrew
chides and nathan weed
and then this like cubitization quantum
walks all these big
tricks uh by uh aikshwan guang haolo
and mario was like all these things came
together so it's wonderful to see how
quantum machine learning benefits from
all these ideas which
which originate from deeply in quantum
physics
but this connection also that was
discovered and and i
for that reason i think just as we don't
expect that
simulating sparse hamiltonians will be
ever feasible on a classical computer
and it's a close connection to some
matrix inversion problems and so on
i don't think so i don't expect that in
the sparse matrix regime
you would be able to become deep
quantize these algorithms
so there i i really expect that just
like hamiltonian simulation you will see
a genuine
quantum speed up however it's very hard
to exploit that speed up as
as scott pointed out in his paper so we
definitely need more work on that
and and some very interesting recent
results that even also attached for
example
this optimized random features paper
where
where the author showed how to
speed up a sampling task for something
which is actually practical in a
learning
argument and gives somehow the optimal
distribution to sample from
this is actually seems to be a very very
useful
thing in this machine learning setting
and due to its connection to sampling
and some other
nice representations of the matrices
this
might be a very interesting candidate
for for getting speed ups
but also because the first supremacy
claims
also showed that quantum computers have
have an edge in something from some
funny distributions
while those distributions may not be
immediately interesting for some
practical tasks but
but you know these authors found a
problem which actually
seems to be relevant for machine
learning and then deep
deep inside it also uh
has some fourier transform involved
somehow the matrices that it uses to
construct uh
it's it's like core core uh subroutine
is uh somehow if i understand correctly
it's the composition of matrices which
are
either sparse in the original basis or
in the fourier basis
and like you can be efficient or
or diagonal or something and maybe you
could efficiently work with either of
those matrices
individually in a classical setting but
once you put a
linear combination of those which is
either nice in the computational
business or adrenalizing the fourier
basis
once you have to work in both bases at
the same time
then classical algorithms have a hard
time and we don't know how to become
they quantize that
and i expect that such kind of settings
will actually defy the quantization
so i'm really interested about the
recent developments
and and i hope that gives the genuine
exponential speed ups eventually
great thanks
ravi so yeah thanks for the very nice
talk i
i'm not so familiar with quantum
computing but uh i
assume she introduced me from the
classical area i was thinking
what i could do usefully was perhaps
tell you of
at least one problem which in which
quantum and classical
may or may not make a difference and we
don't know the answer uh
at least i don't know the answer some of
you might have considered this problem
this is the tensor analog of singular
value
finding so the top singular value of a
matrix
a is just the best x transpose a y
you can get over unit vectors x and y
now if you had a three tensor
uh this applies to any r tensors but
let's say you have a three dimensional
array
a i j k then you can ask for the unit
vectors x
y z which maximize
sum of a i j k x i y j
z k and i think this is n p hard
probably at least
if you go from three to four or five is
np hard but it is known
there is an approximation algorithm
known which for any tensor comes within
an additive factor of epsilon times the
forbidden stone
very similar to our approximation
algorithm for matrices this was in a
paper in 2005 stock or something now
all the linear algebra nice machinery
that you have goes out of the window now
but the sampling article the length
squared sampling article
is again something we use centrally for
this algorithm as velocity other
so for that reason let me throw out this
question and again
i'm not familiar with the recent
literature some of you may know the
answer or may
work out the answer in the next few
minutes but let's throw out the question
is there a quantum advantage
to this can you do better in terms of
error
or the dependence on r when you have an
r tensor it depends on the exponential
in r at the moment for art and this as
our argos but polynomial time in the
other other parameters
so if you have ready-made answers let me
know otherwise by the end of this talk
you can tell me the answer but
okay so uh um we'll we'll circle back to
that by the end of the
end of the panel so um uh
you're done is uh would you like to go
next
sure so yeah uh
first of all thanks erwin for the talk
it's always very nice to
to hear your talk and how you explain
things uh
and how you can see that the work has
evolved and now you're talking about
this very general kind of frameworks
that make a lot of sense and
you know it's something very interesting
even beyond machine learning right
uh so you know i think umesh kind of
posed us a
question uh you know offline or to try
to answer
these two three minis which is is there
a potential for quantum advantage in
machine learning
in quantum machine learning right so i'm
gonna try to
figure out how to answer this question
in two minutes let's say
so guess uh i'm gonna take the maybe the
easy way out and say that the
only reply i can give is that we have to
keep trying right
uh so i cannot say that there will be
but i also
think that you know i don't want to take
the easy way out and say that there's
not going to be so i think the best
thing we can do is keep
trying and there are a few reasons that
i want to give you why we should keep
trying right
so first of all okay machine learning is
important it's pretty
everywhere so i guess if we manage to
get
any enhancement with quantum that's
good right and it's not like we have
million opportunities to find
you know applications and fields where
quantum can very easily provide
advantages so
anyway we can try and get an advantage
i'm happy to to keep working on
on these things and i guess the second
reason is is basically what they
said in in her talk that we have some
very powerful quantum techniques
right which are useful for machine
learning all the singular value
transformation techniques and
different other techniques that will
keep coming up
you know techniques on uh loading data
or estimating distances or some even
newer techniques on how to do volume
sampling and all of these things
at least we have a very good starting
point
right we have a theory that says there
are some very
strong powerful quantum tools that we
can start using
right it's not the end of the story it
doesn't we don't go from there directly
to i have solved all my
machine learning problems but i think
it's a good starting point
and it's also very subtle right these
powerful tools we saw they are very
subtle
and you know we have to be very careful
and read the fine print they totally
agree with
everything that scott said five years
ago or he would repeat
today but i also want us to be to read
the fine print on both sides
in the sense that what do we mean you
know that
we don't have a speed up we mean that
there is no probable exponential speed
up
right and right now we start from a
position that we have
for some problems large polynomial
speedups
okay so it would be much better if
everything was an exponential speed up i
totally agree with you
i will take a speed up which is an order
of eight difference between
linear and and to the eight again
i'm happy to work on this and try to see
if in practice we can we can
we can actually get you know uh a speed
up and if we want to go even more
precise on the on the fine print
i don't think that the real practical
uh running time of this quantum inspired
algorithm
is this end to the 22 12 and all this i
think they're better than that
right i think we all think they're
better than that at the same
time you know i've talked with ravi many
times i've talked to the
magazine and algebra people the question
is are these
are these quantum inspired algorithms
right now
better or worse than the more
traditional classical
linear algebra techniques that people
use right
and for now they are not
faster okay which means that if my goal
is to provide a speed up with the best
possible classical practical algorithm i
still have
you know the cur type of algorithms for
example for
doing recommendation systems which
depend on the dimension
so you can see both ways and i'm trying
to you know to
to say that either what i really want to
say and this is machine learning it's
not an exact science it's not this yes i
want to
see if there is a potential to give a
quantum advantage in practice for some
machine learning application
right and you can either think of it as
an exponential or a large polynomial gap
the question is what will be
you know rest at the end when we try to
implement this
so i agree with scott that if we end up
only
having to to deal with grover maybe
that's not gonna
take us very far right but we do have
much bigger polynomial
uh gaps and much stronger techniques
than just cover
right uh you can do all the spectral
analysis type of stuff right you can't
do fast
things you know phase estimation
singularity estimation all of these
things
i think we should keep working to find
the good
uh applications and
just to you know one last thing is that
to me what i've been trying to do you
know i kind of you know
all of this quantum inspired things is
great and it's starting with this
recommendation systems if i knew that it
would make such a
habit i wouldn't have said it's an
exponential gap i would say it's a big
gap
so then we would have to to do all this
i still think it's a very interesting uh
gap
whether it is exponential and polynomial
and my
what i've been trying to do this this
last four or five years is figure out
really how close can we bring this
algorithms to something that we can see
in reality right
we don't start from the easiest you know
point we need to load the data
we need to have this broken code we need
to do many things
but i don't see a fundamental reason why
i would say that there is no way we can
get this feedback
so as long as there is no fundamental
reason why there shouldn't be
a speed up i'm happy to continue to
to work and on quantum machine learning
and we are you know we are more and more
getting closer to getting all these
leader algebra techniques for example
not
as everyone had an open question and
then not through this as
qsvt framework but much nicer
uh ways of doing the same thing with
much
shallower quantum circuits that implies
that they're also more noise resilient
and so forth
so i stop here you know okay great
thanks thank you can i ask a question
i guess it's in the middle of the panel
so you're saying that um
that when you look at the classical
version this is the qantas quantize and
you compare it to classic
other classical well-studied algorithms
there is no advantage and actually
there's a disadvantage
but i guess comparing running time is
not the only thing and i i'm wondering
if there are some arc applications
architectures where there's some native
operations
which are the same native operations
they're using in the dequantized version
um i'm thinking specifically about
encryption inspired stuff
where some of the polynomial operations
are much easier than other
non kind of linear non operations
uh that it could have an advantage in
such a setting
so it's nice so all i want to say is
that i would not look at
running time as the ultimate test i
would look at sort of what is a natural
operation maybe in another setting and
if these algorithms give you a
completely different type of uh
sort of algorithms maybe they don't but
maybe they do i don't know it's the
first time i've seen this
then that could be interesting okay yeah
can i can i comment um yeah so
um yeah so so if you if you look at the
setting
um where quantum inspired algorithms
work it's actually like a very very
weak like the the set of assumptions are
very very very weak like
it's weaker than like a streaming
assumption it's weaker than like a
um like a sparsity assumption as we
carry like then like the standard
um randomized american linear algebra
assumptions um but they also the
other thing is that it's a little bit of
a strange assumption assumption like um
to have for example sampling query
access to your input
it's a little bit um i'm not aware of
applications that for example
um uh just like tcs generally
where such an application would be
useful
um but i think like i would definitely
be interested to hear
if if such things existed um but yeah
that that's basically like
my understanding for why like these
algorithms i guess are new in some sense
um and and they're the fastest in like
that particular model
um but compare like you know actual
computers
for actual computers you know uh things
like iterating over all the entries are
like
you know reasonable engines and so um
for these reasons
um these algorithms are are
don't necessarily they don't perform as
well as like um
like standard um things like
uh account scheduler or whatever um
and yeah i i guess like
i'm not entirely sure how uh
how practically like how practical even
these these uh
numerical linear algebra sketches are i
guess i i'm not i'm not that sure but
i'm not aware of very many cases where
it's actually used in practice
but um yeah great
okay so uh so
let's let's just continue with the last
panelists who
who patrick who is i think it's very
late for you so
thanks for joining us from singapore and
looking forward to hearing what you have
to say
yeah so i mean first first of all great
talk um ewin
awesome um it's it's great to see all
this coming together
and um also you know advancing the
quantum side the classical side and see
is what kind of speed ups survive and so
on i think that's great
i don't have any any great talk or any
short speech
prepared i mean the some something like
what you showed on the hhl slide i think
that makes that's
that looks actually quite optimistic i
mean quite good right there's still a
large
polynomial gap as also jordan is
mentioned
so that's that sounds at least sounds
quite good for now
um i i believe that the classical
algorithms can be improved and as you
also mentioned i mean the
for example ashley montanaro's recent
paper
uh using the cut schmack meth cut smart
method
um seems to be improving some of these
polynomial
these exponents so i
i mean i am so right now for example i'm
personally i'm working a lot on just
polynomial speedups um just using
standard methods like amplitude
amplification and amplitude estimation
too and um to get small polynomial
speedups
and often we look at sort of
a classical algorithm for a learning
problem and we find the
you know the lines in the code that we
can replace by quantum subroutines and
then
try to figure out what is the overall
speed up and often we get a
again a quadratic speed up in some
variable and sometimes even a slowdown
in other variables
um so we have for example uh
looked at the learning of icing models
um so the
the graph of an icing model the provable
learning
so so um so these are just the things
that i'm looking at and
i mean i'm happy to answer any other
question any specific questions um
great um uh thanks thanks patrick so
before we go on i i want to channel a
virtual
um uh panel member who is a speaker from
last uh the last colloquium uh matthias
troyer
so um uh matthias in his in his talk
um spoke about how anything that's
a quadratic speed up or a sub quadratic
speed up
is is just not going to have any you
know it's not going to provide us a
speed up for
you know not even not just the near
future but the foreseeable future
because quantum computers you know the
the the cycle time is just going to be
so much slower
that um you know you would you would
have uh
just um you would have to go to instant
sizes that are so large that it's really
not going to be practical so
so maybe scott or your don is you know
how how would you react to that you know
to what uh matthias have to say um i
think that that's probably true
i mean you know it i was uh um
you know kind of on the fence about
whether grover speed up
would actually matter in practice in the
near future and and
you know these calculations i think have
made it clear
that you know if they will then it's
going to be not not for quite a long
time
right not not for not for quite a while
and so when one really wants
larger ideally exponential speed up but
you know one thing i was thinking
about uh while i listened to your
adonis's comments
is what examples do we have in all of
quantum computing
of speed ups that are more than
quadratic and less than
exponential right i can think of only
very very few
in in the entire field um you know there
was there was some wim van damme
right had something for some number
theory problem that i think was a
cubic speed up uh um oh oh okay the
hidden sub group problem that's uh yeah
uh sure
sure that's a that's a black box problem
but you go from
two to the n to two to the square root
of n uh thank you like
um the leader algebra once scott
why but then cube linear algebra
problems
from classical right so
the idea is to go from the n-cube things
like pca
or you know volume sampling all of these
kind of
hard linear algebra questions where you
do need this cubic
kind of or almost cubic uh dependence
to get them into linear quantum time
right and we have some examples of that
so this is kind of
a bigger gap let's say that and it's not
based on on glover that you have to do
the queries and things like that
there are not many they're the same
they're not many
anyways even exponential we don't have
mary right
yeah but what matthias says
okay if things do not improve then we're
not going to see anything in practice
right if the hardware doesn't become
faster
if the algorithms don't become better as
in needing
fewer qubits or less time we're not
going to see it
right if everything stays the same we're
not gonna see it
i don't see any i think though it's it's
a
very pessimistic way of thinking right
because if you would ask the same
question
three years ago or before or in three
years
our knowledge changes right so sometimes
it changes for the negative meaning that
we get lower bounds and we say okay
we were trying but we're not going to
get it but most of the times we get new
algorithms
like the biggest not right one i'm none
of this was an argument for not looking
certainly right go to agreement about
that
uh you know but i mean finding new
algorithms cuts both ways because it's
finding new quantum algorithms also
finding new classical ones
right sure sure yeah my goal is to find
you algorithms let's say right
yeah yeah yeah yeah great so ian
you had uh maybe do you want to respond
to
this comment i
not i mean i don't i don't really have
much to say um i also think it's like i
mean
i think what uh um
like the this the stuff um these like
um that that more than grover is
probably necessary
is um it seems reasonable and that's i
think why
like um
[Music]
um
yeah i think i think that's uh
that's interesting because it does cut
down a lot on like
the number of possible machine learning
applications
if you um like um like ones that that
seem actually
feasible to implement uh in in the short
term
um yeah i don't have very many thoughts
okay great um i i had a quick question
uh actually turning to patrick um
you know in terms of um in terms of this
other approach you know with some sort
of a variational approach to quantum
machine learning where you
you know where one starts with a number
of qubits which is
modest you know 50 100 you know 200
but but which is which is very hard to
simulate classically
and then one says look you know
variationally we are training something
and
maybe it does something so it's
something that we can't do classically
so
what would you say to to that type of
approach and
what what are what are the possibilities
there and
you know how how optimistic should we be
about that that
i think for um for applications like in
chemistry i think um
we can be quite optimistic i would say i
mean um
the variational approach has been used
in chemistry on classical computers
so i think in general um i would believe
the chemistry would be
if at all the first application of these
methods
machine learning may be after but um i
believe that chemistry
chemistry because i mean the chemical
problem itself is a quantum mechanical
problem
and so it's uh it will probably um
be easier for near-term quantum
computers to
to provide some sort of insight into
these chemical problems
by the way i should have mentioned
before but there's a whole world of
machine learning problems that are for
quantum problems
right that uh uh you know are about
learning a quantum state and where you
know there is no
barrier at all it seems to getting
exponential quantum speed ups
but you know i just i took it that that
wasn't what we were talking about
yeah but um but uh while you're at it's
got is it
you know is there a particularly
striking
uh you know example of such a quantum
machine learning uh you know with
quantum states
problem right well there again i would
say you know it's
uh it's not obvious what uh
what what what the examples are i mean
you know you there are
machine learn you can imagine machine
learning tasks where
quantum simulation would be a subroutine
in them right like maybe
you know learning the behavior of a
protein for example
you know based on on on on various data
right and uh
you know the you know that that might be
you know that that in the end
it's heuristic and there's not really a
rigorous analysis
but for the quantum simulation part in
the middle
you know for that we believe that
there's an exponential speed up uh but
yeah
it would be great to have something
better
even there right
yeah if i may add like one of the
problems with quantum machine learning
it is it's just
hard to input this large data into the
small quantum computers that we have
so if we start with some quantum
mechanical model and like generate the
quantum data on the fly then we don't
have the problem of like having to
measure the quantum state on the first
place
and we also solve the problem of the
input of the quantum machine learning
algorithm so
like like one of the examples that that
like people say that maybe
uh quantum simulation will be useful for
understanding some
catalysts like nitrogenase but it's it's
also a bit unclear to me how
would a quantum stimulation help in
understanding that molecule
how would they use the of the simulation
maybe
maybe the ultimate approach fish filled
in that somehow you simulate the
molecule
and you respond to machine learning to
understand the structure which is like
the underlying key features that that
makes
your understanding whatever need to be
and there like the input is small and
the output is small
and in between the the large i
input output uh like intensive part
which is the problem in quantum machine
learning
is solved by this dislike keeping
everything quantum mechanical
i think that that is one of the key
messages in this block encoding that
that don't convert your data back to
classical just keep it always quantum
and that seems to help a lot so one
other
one other cases when you have to
pre-process
your data with again with something
linear algebraic like do a pca
or or project it into some subspace or
or
make do a kernel so there the bottleneck
is not the dimension of the
of your data but it's the fact that you
have to do this cubic operation
on it right so there even if your
quantum
uploading of data takes linear time
you're still getting if the mapping the
pci for example or the kernel
can be done fast then you end up with a
quantum state as you need it
in the computation which is much faster
than the cubic
thing that you would need to do
classically
so this is also another case where you
can do the pre-processing
quantumly this is what we did in the
recommendation systems as well right
you you project your your user in the
top
subspace and then you keep the you keep
it as a quantum state
right this is the thing that is
difficult and that's why you're getting
this 6
8 12 hours so it's not just loading the
data
right great
um like ike trung has a question mike
yeah inspired by what you've been asking
umesh and
your answers those of you on the panel
um it occurred to me the following
because um you know when i was a postdoc
with mesh you mess you
you inspired me instilled in me this
this
firm belief that quantum will have no
advantage
if there's no structure to the problem
and that the only case where you
expect an advantage is if there is some
kind of structure because it
that structure may match the nature of
quantum mechanics
underlying it and if you ask a physicist
an experimentalist almost no
experimentalists except those who are
motivated by other concerns let's say
believe in qram
and i certainly don't believe in kiram
and have never believed that we would
ever be able to physically realize a
qram
now on the other hand scott and folks
have been raising
um patrick and company that the point
that
chemistry is very uh appealing and
machine learning
questions in chemistry but if you're an
experimental physicist and you
you ask yourself where is the structure
of hard quantum questions
it's not in pure quantum systems it's in
noisy quantum systems
so my question to you in the panel is
how how would we think about block
encoding
noisy quantum processes where the
quantum process
is not just a unitary or a hermitian or
a hamiltonian
but rather something that has classical
noise
classical stochastic as well as scott
yawning at me
at the same time because it should
really be hard
quantum and classical what do you think
sorry scott
i think you owe yourself the first
answer since you found this
me i don't know
i mean you know we know we know ways to
to deal with noise i mean you know i
mean i mean often
you can do it by just passing to a
larger you know
hilbert space and just tracing part of
it out
uh you know now there is work like my
my uh former post doc chong hao wang and
then richard cleave
you know did some work on on can you
know in what cases can you do better
than that like if you have wind blood
evolution
you know and you want to simulate it you
know when can you do better than uh
passing to a larger hilbert space but at
the very least you can always do that
but i want something more efficient
because i i suspect that distinguishing
two distributions which are noisy
quantum distributions
classical noise added to quantum is
probably a great model for
the hardest machine learning problems
and those which we might expect a
quantum advantage for
i don't know i mean you know often when
people say oh uh uh
you know the the the the the presence of
noise just just you know um enhances
things for us
or it means that you know we're more
likely to get a quantum speed up
you know in the past that has often been
a red flag for me
right it's uh um uh
you know like the the the the the
history of
claims of that kind i think has not been
a
a strong one because you know the the
the the intuition is as you would expect
as you add more noise to something it
becomes easier to simulate classically
uh you know and if there are examples
going against that i'd be very
interested to see them
there is a great example which is the
the one from
ibm with small uh graham smith
and andrew cross right of what was a
parody checking with noise
uh and and in that case uh it is a
simple kind of machine learning problem
and they find that there's an
exponential advantage
for the quantum algorithm over the
classical as the noise increases
largely because the quantum algorithm
was immune to the noise
so the noise was structured in a
particular quantum way
but i submit to you that what we're
missing is a classical framework to be
able to handle these cases
where the noise is structured in a
quantum mechanical way
i don't know okay yes i i'm not sure
what you mean by the noise being
structured if you want to send me a link
to that paper which i don't know i'd be
happy to take a look at it
just um one one quick thing for for
you and before uh you know so soon we
are getting to
towards the end of the panel um i put a
gather town link on the
on the chat for anyone who wants to join
join afterwards
but even just very quickly um you know
in your
in your chart that you showed you know
as as things moved you know from
potential exponential advantage and
you know towards more and more likely
not in in that
in that graph there were a few things
that still stood out in the potential
uh exponential advantage um
can you say a little bit about what you
see as the most promising ones of those
and uh you know just maybe a couple of
sentence description of those particular
problems
um yeah so
um i guess
the ones that i thought were the most
interesting
i um discussed already so so
um the ones that were the most most
yellow for the gaussian process
regression which um
i discussed it um it's a
it's an interesting um
i don't really know what gaussian
process regression is i think it has
something to do with um
like like basically it's like some sort
of regression and
it involves like a gaussian kernel um
but uh i think i think this has been
like
floating around for a while um and
um i guess it
uses some i think heuristic arguments to
say that like
um that you could sparsify the matrices
that you want to invert
and then use a like hhl um
and the the same basically holds true
for the for the topological data
analysis
there there you're assuming that it's
sparse
and then using it to um i guess
your year you want to estimate the
dimension of the
kernel of like a combinatorial laplacian
um and um
this is a little bit it's a little bit
strange
to do such a thing because the way that
you estimate it is you
um estimate the
you don't estimate like like you don't
get an approximation of the curve
dimension exactly
you you get you approximate all of the
singular
values and then you just truncate and
like
assume that everything that's
sufficiently small is um
is zero and so you don't actually get an
actu
a real approximation um algorithm in
this
in the sense of like a ratio or
something um so you so
um i think there's been recent work sort
of talking about
um possible reasons why this might
give some speed ups um there was a paper
recently that sort of says that a
generalization
uh can be used to simulate the one clean
qubit model i'm
it's getting a little far far from my
area of expertise
um but um
i i also agree with androsh that like
this example
with um learning optimized random
features is very interesting
um one of the downsides is that it does
use
qram um i guess like they all use qram
and that makes it
um that makes me somewhat skeptical of
like any of these applications
um to be honest um
and uh
like um so so
it's uh not clear to me how
like uh my my job is not usually to like
think about like okay what's like the
most practical machine learning
algorithm
and so um uh i don't usually need to
think about these concerns
um but i i i'm not actually sure about
like
whether i would consider these like i
would definitely consider all of the
ones that were on my slide
to be far from practical um
in um a lot of senses i mean
uh but but probably like primarily the
fact that they use
use qram um
and um
[Music]
yeah i guess it's it's just uh um
something i would like definitely
consider uh like maybe
more uh more interesting on the
practical side would be something like
like i think like um aaron harrell gave
a talk recently
that was about like quadratic speed ups
um but that didn't have
like such large assumptions like qram
and things like this
um and i thought those like um
like i agree that like quadratic speed
ups are also maybe
not that viable for like quantum speed
ups in the short term but i think
they're also like uh
you know maybe they're more viable than
like a qram
based system i'm not sure yeah
um did i answer the question yeah no
that was
that was good and uh you even proposed a
hierarchy of what uh you know what might
be more or less viable which
which is interesting yeah no that's uh
it's great so i i think we should um you
know we are we are really um
uh this this was a great discussion we
can continue
this on gather town if anybody wants to
join
and uh i just want to wrap up by
thanking the panel uh for all the
comments and and
of course thank you you and for you know
always
for this um great talk and um
see you all next week yeah i apologize i
have to teach i can't make the gather
town but uh thank you for inviting me
and thank you even
thanks everyone thank you bye
hi see you see you all